The great thing about modules is, not only do they allow us to organize our own
code better, then allows us to share code with other people. And sharing is a
great thing, it allows us to write much more interesting programs, much more
quickly than if we had to write everything ourselves. One very useful module
that we could have used for the search engine, if we were using modules instead
of learning by writing all the code ourselves, is this great Python library for
processing web pages, known as Beautiful Soup. And you can see the Beautiful
Soup page here. There's a link to it in the instructor comments as well. And to
use it, first you need to download it. As long as you've got that Python Package
Manager already set up, which most of you probably do, if you've installed the
standard version of Python. You can do it just using this command. Unlike other
modules that we've imported so far, Beautiful Soup is not part of the standard
Python library. So to use it, you have to install it first. If you have pip
installed this is really easy. Pip is a Python Package installer. All we would
need to do is this, it would know how to download it and install it, and set it
up to work on your machine. If you don't have pip installed already, there are
directions for how to set up pip, in the instructor comments. It's very useful
to set this up, makes it much easier to install packages after that. Now that
we've installed Beautiful Soup, we can import it into our search engine code.
And instead of all the code that we wrote for extracting links, we can use what
Beautiful Soup already provides.